i think envy absolutely does not make
you happy
but i do think that envy will make you
successful
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of the game
uh what i want to talk to you about
today was a conversation that i had with
nick bayerly we went to dinner um
last night he has a a mastermind of men
uh called billion dollar uh billion
dollar brotherhood
and uh we were having conversation about
motivation and i figured i'd share with
you because i think it was
of a lot of value and so i was sharing
that recently
i had delineated between the feelings of
envy
and jealousy and how important it has
been for me
to be able to first name those emotions
so that i could then
analyze how i was feeling about them and
the actions that i would subsequently
take as a result of them
and so i want to at least first cover
those and then i'll tell you about our
conversation and so
envy is having the the desire
for something that someone else has that
you do not have so you are lacking and
someone else has something that you want
and do not have that is
envy jealousy is when you
have a threat that someone is going to
take something
that you have that they do not have all
right
and so for example i'll give you an
example of each so envy i may be envious
of a friend of mine so um i was actually
talking to a good friend of mine who
runs a big weight loss company
and right now he's doing better than i
am and now i am envious
of his success i am i can feel it i'm
envious i got off the phone i was like i
am envious of you right
on the flip side if someone comes to
talk to
layla right it is the fact that they
pose the threat of taking attention or
her attention that i think
should continuously belong to me that i
would feel jealous over i haven't had i
haven't felt jealousy in a long time
but that is that is an example it could
also be like with your kids if you have
some you know some other adult in their
life starts
taking their attention or has more
influence over them you are jealous of
the influence that that person is now
is threatening your influence over your
child right so two examples they're
nuanced but i think it's important
and when i was talking to nick barely
about this i was talking about how i
think
envy um gets a bad rap and i'm not going
to go into the spiritual religious side
of this or even the happiness side of
this because i think envy absolutely
does not make you happy
but i do think that envy will make you
successful all right and so this this is
where i want to kind of dive into this
envy is adaptive right as human beings
this is actually from our old brain
right this is animals have this too they
are envious of one another
and it's because if in a group one
person
or one being one animal whatever brings
more to the table you are now envious of
that person and what it does is it
elevates the rest of the group to go
and achieve the same which is good for
the collective not
happier for each of the individuals but
is a pro survival tool
right and so for me understanding this
and at least being able to name the
emotion rather than saying i don't like
this guy or i'm angry at this person
or having this negative feeling that you
cannot put words to
instead being able to say i am envious
has been very relieving for me because
now i can actually
tell those people hey i'm envious of you
and for some reason i think it just
creates another level of candor because
it's a certain level of vulnerability
and saying
you have something that i wish i had but
then you'll
notice that the conversation is not
defensive on that person's part
most of the time they're like well let
me help you and it's only when we guide
our intentions or try and
or try and feign you know pretend to be
a different way than we are
where people also can sense that you're
being disingenuous
like a great job man right when you
realize deep down and they can tell from
your
your subtle tonality changes and the way
you look that the
um that you're actually not happy for
them right and so i think if you can
only say it then it actually gives you
power
now in terms of judging your motivations
because obviously you might think that
envy is a bad uh motivation it is my
belief
that i would rather deal with people who
do good things for bad reasons than bad
reasons for good things
or i said the same thing twice but uh
they do the right thing for the wrong
reasons rather than the wrong
things for the right reason all right
i'd rather someone who does the right
outcome
and he gave me an example that was
really powerful
he said a friend of his um was a top
navy seal
and uh you know one of the best navy
seals he trains navy seals just a
total badass right and before that he
was an emt
and he talked about his experience as
being an emt is that most people think
you know emts have to be really caring
you want them to you know they have to
save these people's lives every day
and he said uh the navy seal was saying
i
was not compassionate at all i didn't
really care that much about the person
who was on the table in front of me
but what i did care about was my stats i
cared about the status of being the best
i wanted to have the fastest of the
hospital i want to have the highest
survival rates highest success rates
of the people that were under my care
because i cared about myself being the
best
and so the question is if you were the
person who was on the table having a
heart attack
would you rather have the compassionate
emt
or would you rather have the
self-interested emt
who is doing it for status well if it
were me i'd rather have the guy who
wanted to pride himself on being the
best in the world and didn't even care
about me at all
because i knew his result was going to
be more pro-me than the other persons
and so i think that as as humans as
entrepreneurs we judge ourselves a lot
on our motivations and our
in our intentions but i think that if we
can take a step back and a
name the emotion so that's not this
amorphous thing that we can't understand
but then take the next step and say is
this is this a
pro adaptive emotion is this something
that's going to help me
or is this an emotion that's going to
drive me to do something that is
negative
and i think at least even even in naming
that we can increase the time between
emotion and action
and the further that time gap is in
general
the better the quality of the decisions
we make because the more rational we are
we're never completely rational because
we're
we're emotion driven beings and we have
limbic systems that override things
but the more we can decrease the
triggers of the emotional triggers that
that cause us to make bad decisions
ultimately the better decisions we make
and so i i say all this to say
big picture first naming the emotions is
important
second it creates space so we can make
better decisions
third we can analyze those decisions and
say is this something that is going to
help me
in my life or is this something that's
going to hurt me and then as a result of
this
we don't have to judge ourselves as
strongly on
why we are doing things and rather
what is being done uh because candidly i
am a very envious individual and maybe
this is me just
um rationalizing my own negative
you know emotions who knows but at least
for me
saying it that way and framing the
thought process in that way has helped
me
feel better about myself and just not or
really just
less bad if that's probably a better way
of saying it and not
constantly berating myself for having
desires that i think
are wrong and so dan sullivan said this
and i'll end with this
is that when people want something if
you want to make more money if you want
to have a bigger house you want to have
a bigger car you want to build a podcast
studio whatever
right he said wanting is reason enough
because so many times we ask but why do
we want that
we're probably not going to change the
desire and so
letting us letting ourselves desire
things and giving ourselves permission
to desire things
uh and myself specifically um has been
incredibly freeing
and what it's done has given me a
tremendous amount of my attention back
that used to be allocated to analyzing
why i'm feeling this way
or why this is right or why this is
wrong
and instead accepting the fact that i
want something and that wanting it is
okay
as long as it is not something that is
hurting other people and that is not
something that is hurting me
and so anyways i hope that makes sense i
hope that provided you some value or
hopefully maybe some clarity around
putting words to your own emotions the
decisions that results from them
and whether they are positive or
negative and eliminating the judgment
from that equation
provided it's something that helps so
anyways keep being awesome keep you
amazing and have
an awesome great magic money day catch
you soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
you